si les j'aimerais qu'on découvre ton
côté obscur ce soir ouais question cyril
tueur voiture un mec tu grille la
priorité est de fait une queue de
poisson
qu'est ce que tu lui dis connard ont
reculé ce année pour noël endroit la
bagnole c'est l'endroit où je suis le
plus vulgaire
alors là mais l'album allemand la villa
il a tu sortes ta tête tu déconnes à et
là tu vois un mec qui sont allés voter
d'ailleurs je disais il est à élaborer
en tulle est ouest a dit ce n'est pas du
coup l'élève pendant une pub de tpm pays
à gilles verdez qui vient de susurrer à
l'oreille tu es un connard tu fais quoi
tan dung mais moi j'ai eu moi j'ai pas
une voix ridicule delphine ernotte sans
voix sms delphine ernotte la patronne de
france télé pour te dire s'il était
gentil mais je vais te dire c'est la fin
pour toi tu pars rejoindre le club de ce
que j'écrirai tu réponds quoi c'est pas
grave
j'irai chez nous ne la regarde
irrespectueux des grandes carrières et
qui était pas viré et qui sont chez nous
il y avait pour projet de faire un move
c'était dans les tuyaux 1 il ya ton ex
qui t'a fait le plus souffrir
quitte à tromper qui a abusé de la
confiance qui te regardent ce soir tu
envie de lui dire quoi je ne te les
jamais dit mais j'ai couché avec ta
soeur
les magasins en fait il y eut d'abord
avec le jus apprend par un ami que j'ai
dit du mal de toi tu me crois dans la
rue tu fais quoi au nom que tu as dit du
mal de moi imaginons ce que tous mes
amis me disent que tu dit que du bien
témoin en plus donc il faut que je
balançais pas l'horreur lasse pas
crédible et de leurs mots à eux donc il
est dit du mal de moi ils sont aux
coudes et kim souffre toujours du bien
soit tout dire adieu sa nouvelle
émission
soudas tu te rends compte qu'un candidat
de slam triche il lui demande de
s'excuser mais rien n'y fit tu regarde
droit dans les yeux et tu te dis va dit
qu'est ce tu vas faire j'appelle mokhtar
et va te défonce
[Applaudissements]